Stéphane Plaza parle de son alcoolisme
les personnalités ont telle raison de
parler de leurs démons on va passer à ce
sujet à ce sujet pardon pipolémique
est-ce qu'il y a un sujet ou pas
non merci beaucoup donc c'est pas le
premier en parler évidemment Pierre
Palmade avec le drame qui est arrivé on
avait parlé Jean-Marie Bigard la
chanteuse rose et la cocaïne Jérémy
Ferrari et l'alcool alors est-ce que
c'est bien d'en parler ou pas on avait
fait ce sujet pour les maladies et à
l'époque avec Pernaut et tout ça ce
qu'il faut dire qu'on est malade pas
malade est-ce que ça aide les gens
est-ce que au contraire ça fait du pitié
c'est des vrais sujets ce qu'il faut
être pudique pas pudique moi mon
meilleur ami d'enfance qui a 14 ans m'a
dit si un jour j'ai un cancer tu ne
seras pas c'est très c'est voilà c'est
est-ce qu'il faut en parler ou pas Plaza
il dit qu'il en est à 200 jours sans
alcool il a craqué une fois à Noël
Bigard nous annonçait aussi les jours il
compte il compte en permanence donc
voilà Plaza il a posté sur Instagram
c'est un grand pas 200 jours presque 100
alcool monsieur accordé des occasions
cher à mon coeur 5 6 verres c'est vrai
que certains racontent beaucoup aussi
que quand on était invité à des fêtes le
champagne ça va très vite c'est une
coupe de coupe trois coupes et j'ai des
potes qui me disaient ben tu arrives à
deux bouteilles de champagne de la
soirée et si tu es un peu attaché de
presse et que tu fais ça tous les soirs
de tel que lui qui est tout simplement
alors ces stars qui parlent de leur
dépendance à l'alcool il y en a beaucoup
il y a eu Véronique Sanson
il y a eu hier dans Libération la
planète son ancien édition à la cocaïne
aussi Renault Renault évidemment donc
d'abord j'aimerais avoir un tour de
table et puis on part on parlera de tout
le monde bah peut-être de vous aussi
parce que je savais pas du tout et vous
en parler est-ce qu'il faut parler de
ces addictions quand on est
en fait oui moi je trouve ça bien parce
que les gens connus souvent sont
pris soit en exemple où ça sont des
influences pour le monde et c'est bien
aussi qu'il puisse témoigner et rappeler
qui sont comme tout le monde
et que les gens que les gens puissent en
tout cas s'identifier
que les gens
moi je trouve ça chouette que les gens
puissent s'identifier dans une
reconstruction et je trouve ça super
chouette quoi on n'est pas toujours en
train de faire croire que tout est
parfait il y a des noms avec Natacha oui
c'est-à-dire que dans le cadre d'une
biographie
[Rires]
simplement parce que dans le cadre d'une
biographie il y a quelque chose de
cohérent on raconte une vie on raconte
les hauts et les bas donc il y a on suit
si vous voulez tout un parcours et et
comme l'histoire enfin voilà un
personnage de roman qui se trouve être
réel mais dans comme ça faire une
déclaration sur une addiction ou sur un
problème qui peut parfois amener à une
certaine déchéance et tout je trouve que
ça c'est un petit peu trop brutal
frontal et je trouve ça casse un peu le
rêve et c'est vrai que certains acteurs
avaient dit je suis plus lequel qui
avait dit moi un jour j'ai parlé d'un
problème avec la drogue ou je sais pas
quoi en trois lignes et c'était il y a
quelques années bon ben c'est fini on me
parle que de ça dans les interviews et
quand je vais faire un rôle au cinéma
c'est terminé oui Benoît te dis non moi
je dis non parce que c'est pareil comme
Natacha je trouve que ça abîme l'image
de l'artiste après on l'invite que pour
ça et après c'est la porte ouverte à ce
que vous voulez une fois que l'artiste
se dit maintenant on sait que je suis
drogué et bourré je peux le faire quand
je veux de toute façon c'est comme ça je
suis malade alors que quand on regarde
pour nous on ne le dit pas on essaye
d'être un maximum clean quand on se
présente dans des endroits
et tu dis que tu as décidé d'arrêter que
tu veux t'en sortir du coup tu prends un
engagement public de vos amis
le fait que tu t'engages et ben je
trouve ça te force un peu à tenir le
public on s'écoute
engagé et ben tu dis merde il faut le
public qui veut voir c'est la chute de
l'artiste à chaque fois qu'il y a des
images dégueulasses et bien sûr à chaque
fois qu'ils ont des problèmes de drogue
ou d'alcool qu'est-ce qu'on attend les
reportages et il en est où et ce qui va
aller c'est trop bien sûr que si les
gens se nourrissent du malheur des
autres parce que ça les rend plus
heureux là où je rejoins un peu Benoît
c'est que j'ai vu un truc et le premier
truc que j'avais eu c'est il a fait de
ce qu'ils appellent rehab ça veut dire
des cours de désintox c'est le premier
truc que tu dis dans la presse people
François Cluzet par exemple c'est vrai
parler de ses problèmes d'alcool reste
il en a parlé une fois qu'il avait eu un
César et que ça marchait pour lui
d'accord c'est bien parce que j'ai mis
l'argent
peut-être beaucoup de gens qui
s'identifient à ces célébrités qui les
voient comme nous
il y a beaucoup c'est vraiment c'est ce
que vous approchez pas tous en même
temps mais tu penses que Florence c'est
quelqu'un est chez lui à 17h qu'il est
chômeurs et qui boit il se dit François
Cluzet arrêté je vais m'arrêter si les
gens si les gens lisent la presse people
si les gens regardent cette émission si
les gens s'intéressent autant aux
célébrités c'est que peut-être qu'il
leur accorde un crédit qu'il n'accorde
pas à monsieur ou madame tout le monde
donc si ces personnes le font et le font
bien comme disait Jean-Michel dans une
perspective d'aider les autres bah c'est
non seulement c'est passionnant mais
c'est constructif et ça les empêche pas
de continuer à réussir s'ils sont bien
structurés comme
moi je dis plutôt oui mais ça dépend
aussi le degré de sincérité la façon de
la façon dont laquelle c'est fait et
puis surtout pardon vous oubliez que
très souvent ils répondent à des
interviews ils font pas des déclarations
et ils connaissent le secteur ils savent
exactement qui en prend ils mettent dans
l'entonnoir souvent
rappelez-moi que un tout petit peu
journaliste encore quand même donc je
sais comment ça se passe et après
effectivement ad vitam eternam on
reprend les propos qu'ils ont dit à un
endroit donc ils sont condamnés à le
répéter systématiquement arrêtons de
dire que les gens font des déclarations
spontanées comme ça poussent un souci je
vous dis un truc qui n'a aucun rapport
mais il a regretté toute sa vie le fils
il y a pour jouer un jour pour raconter
un jour une connerie il a dit qu'il
avait un zizi ça fait 20 ans que c'est
partout dans la presse et que le mec ça
l'insupporte et que c'était une
quand même
alors juste pour vous dire que il y a eu
François que j'ai bien sûr de par Dieu
mais ça n'a pas pu ça continue ça jamais
Biolay qui dit que il est vraiment sorti
beaucoup beaucoup qui s'est il s'est
abîmé dans les nuits Patrick Sébastien
qui devait jusqu'à plus une bouteille de
whisky par jour Christophe Lambert
également bon Loana Jean-Marie Bigard
qu'elle a parlé il a arrêté il y a pas
longtemps il a parlé dans un canard
people absolument j'ai alors après c'est
maintenant c'est devenu nouveau truc un
peu c'est un peu lors de mes trio des
mecs maintenant c'est tout le monde mais
c'est vrai tout le monde annonce tu as
un problème je sais pas si votre toi tu
toi tu dis oui aussi ah ouais moi je dis
oui oui puis surtout j'ai envie de dire
c'est souvent lire un processus
psychologique de ces artistes mais si tu
as envie d'en parler c'est pas
simplement parce qu'un journaliste pose
la question c'est plutôt pas forcément
très courageux les journalistes Isabelle
excuse-moi parfois sur le sujet mais en
vrai c'est parce que ça correspond un
truc ok je le dis aujourd'hui et j'en
parle Marie par exemple parler de est-ce
que c'est mauvais ou pas ou bien de dire
ou pas dire Jean-Marie Bigard je suis
souvent fritée avec lui j'aime beaucoup
Jean-Marie mais à l'antenne et j'ai dit
des trucs pas toujours sympa sur lui
mais depuis qu'il est revenu sur TPMP
c'est un autre Jean-Marie et ça lui fait
vachement bien aujourd'hui et j'ai envie
de dire tous les gens qu'on son âge plus
jeune et qui voit et qui boivent et qui
voit que ce mec bah il est revenu à la
table de TP bien sûr et que tout va bien
pour lui je trouve que c'est plus
d'accord et Plaza pardon Plaza il
continue de faire ses émissions il aura
rien il aura aucun problème ça m'agace
un peu c'est pas un jeu juste une
question vous buviez beaucoup c'est quoi
le colique moi je sais pas ce que vous
appelez alcoolique mais je me faisais du
mal avec l'alcool et
je m'en servais pour me détruire et le
24 décembre 2016 j'ai décidé de plus
jamais boire une goutte d'alcool donc ça
fait 6 ans bravo
[Applaudissements]